no question that are just as Eric
optimum historian said that the 20th
century began with the assassination of
the Archduke Ansari avo that triggered
off the First World War so two one could
say that the 21st century began with 911
because it's it's transformed the way in
which governments have reacted
especially the US but other governments
to to the threats and the dangers of the
world in which we live not always for
the wisest or for the best but it's
therefore left to mark in a shape on the
kind of world we live and everything
from the kinds of airport security we
have now we live in a world where you
can't carry a bottle of water through
the security check and it's crazy but
it's also part of the ways in which the
war against terror or the fear of
terrorism whatever you want to call it
daily impacts our lives in ways that
colonies